at a weekend Community class in the
Manila suburb
these children are learning how to read
it's a skill that by global standards
should have been Mastered by the age of
10. but Kian borcione who is in the
fourth grade still struggles to read in
his native Filipino
when English is an even greater
challenge
no
and numbers are equally difficult
four
plus six
these children have been attending class
remotely since the covid-19 pandemic
began in 2020. most restrictions were
only lifted this year
mothers are busy with work or with
chores at home they may not have enough
time to tutor their kids which is a huge
part of distance learning
the result is a further setback in the
quality of Education not only for the
Philippines but for most low and middle
income countries the quality of learning
among Filipino school kids was already
poor in pre-pandemic times in 2019 only
around 30 percent could read simple
texts or understand a simple Story by
the age of 10. international Aid
agencies say that number has now dropped
to less than 20 percent
on Monday schools opened for in-person
classes for the first time in two years
covid-19 is still very much a concerned
with temperature checks face masks and
regular hand washing the norm
education department acknowledges that
the bigger problem is learning
deficiency we have a program that's
called every child is able to read so
that's an after-school program that we
are launching with the help of credited
tutors and teachers so that we could
sort of focus on the literacy skills of
our children
the government hopes that presuming
face-to-face classes will improve the
quality of Education to better equip
these children in an increasingly
competitive world
Manila